اندلعت مواجهاتنا في شوارع رئيسه بمدينه
تل ابيب بين الشرطه ومحتاجين على خطط
الحكومه اجراء تعديلات في جهاز القضاء
واستخدمت الشرطه قنابل الصوت والدخان
لتفريق المحتجين الذين اغلقوا شارع ايلون
الرئيسي كما اعلنت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعتقاله 39 متظاهرا جراء ما سمته اعمال
شغب وفوضى وعصيان اوامر الشرطه في المقابل
وصف وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ايتامار
بنكير المتظاهرين بالفوضويين واطالب
الشرطه بمنعهم من اغلاق محاور الطرق
الرئيسه
وقد هاجم رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو معارضي خطته لاضعاف الجهاز
القضائي وقال انهم يقودون الدوله الى
الفوضى وان المعارضه تتصرف بعدم مسؤوليه
مطلقه على حد وصفه واجرى نتنياه مقارنه
بين منفذ اعتداءات بلده حوار والمحتجين ضد
خطته واصفا الحدثين باعمال عنف وانه لن
يسمح بتجاوز الخطوط الحمر
قلت لمثيرين شغب في حواره اننا لن نحتمل
وضعا يقوم فيه كل شخص بالتصرف كما يحلو له
واقولها ثانيه لمثير الشغب الذين تجاوزوا
الخطوط الحمراء في تل ابيب لن نحتمل وضعا
يتصرف فيه كل شخص وفق ما يريد لن نقبل
باعمال عنف او الاعتداء على رجال الشرطه
او اغلاق شوارع او تهديد شخصيات عامه
وابناء عائلاتهم وهو ما يحدث حاليا في قلب
تل ابيب لن نقبل بكسر القوانين والقواعد
ولا باعمال عنف لا في حواره ولا في تل
ابيب ولا في اي مكان اخر